hola a todos
como están
nosotros estamos contentísimos de lanzar
este programa y les agradecemos
muchísimo a todos los profesores
mexicanos que están viéndonos ahorita y
los que nos van a ver cuando tengan
tiempo porque el día de hoy es un día
muy especial para tanto para acá
canakkale mí como para ustedes porque
lanzamos el producto o programa que se
llama campeonato un programa que nos va
a ayudar a impulsar y motivar a sus
estudiantes a aprender y aprender de una
manera diferente no en la que ellos
puedan ver su progreso puedan celebrar
con ustedes y verlos a ustedes como
mentores del aprendizaje no entonces
le cedo la palabra a patti para que
arranquemos ya con mucha emoción el
programa ya dejamos tan de tanto hablar
y los vamos a poner en práctica todo lo
que ha gustado hablando nada para que
sepan un poco sobre la sesión por si ven
cosas que ya vieron antes estas sesiones
están hechas para reforzar conceptos
para profesores que son nuevos o
profesores y todavía no
o bien cómo funciona khan academy y lo
que queremos hacer es que encuentren
tanto el material que tiene khan academy
el programa fácilmente entonces estamos
haciendo estas sesiones que son como
sesiones de apoyo no sé si ustedes
tienen cualquier duda obviamente nos
pueden escribir pero bueno estas
sesiones están hechas para ayudarlos y
apoyarlos entonces os dejo a patti que
les presente la agenda y el programa del
día de hoy y arrancamos sin ningún
retraso
hola a todos bienvenidos qué gusto
tenerlos aquí nuevamente pues llegó
finalmente el gran día empieza hoy a
campeonato arrancamos después de tantos
preparativos tanta preparación tanto
tiempo invertido bueno llegó el gran día
así que nos da un enorme gusto estar
aquí con ustedes no en esta otra vez
pequeña revisión o de qué es lo que
tenemos que hacer para ser campeones
dentro de este increíble programa de
decana acá de mí no es una gran
oportunidad para todos como maestros y
sobre todo para los que son más
importantes que son nuestros alumnos no
darles esta oportunidad de comenzar el
año escolar con con el pie derecho así
que bienvenidos esta es la liga para
para esta presentación vamos a hacerlo
como en otras capacitaciones esto va a
ser una especie de taller para aquellos
maestros que apenas están negadas
iniciándose con khan academy para hacer
que sepan cómo abrir una clase cómo
asignar recursos etcétera no entonces
pueden entrar a la presentación si
quieres adrianita por lo en el chat jeje
puntos teje diagonal de 16 z
todo con minúsculas y en caso de no
tener su dispositivo a la mano bueno les
recomiendo que tomen una foto a la
pantalla para que más adelante la puedan
agregar a su trago o bajar en su
instalar en su computador
seguimos bueno que vamos a ver o no
vamos a ver cuáles son los primeros
pasos que debemos seguir para sumarme al
campeonato no aquellos maestros que
están entrando por primera vez o que
este su primer webinar pues vamos a
revisar como creamos la cuenta como
creamos clases como eliminamos clases
antiguas que ya no estamos utilizando
que esa parte es muy muy importante y
ahora les explicaremos por qué como
asignó el contenido a mis estudiantes
como puedo tener acceso a los reportes
maravillosos que cada canal
khan academy me ofrece y también les
vamos a compartir algunas ideas para
participar para motivar a sus alumnos
para no para esther pues agradece nos lo
agradeceré reconocerles no se esfuerzos
y sus logros etcétera y también vamos a
hablar sobre todos los puntos
importantes que debemos saber sobre
campeonato ahora que estamos comenzando
como me inscribo como puedo checar el
tablero de progreso que es mentalidad de
crecimiento y también nos vamos a hablar
sobre una sorpresa que tiene canal
de mí para los profesores participantes
que es un kit de clase entonces vamos a
comenzar con como creo mi cuenta lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es entrar
a ese punto khan academy punto org esto
automáticamente nos va a llevar a la
plataforma en español de khan academy si
ustedes ya bajaron la presentación con
que hagan clic aquí automáticamente los
va a llevar
es un híper enlace los va a llevar
automáticamente a la plataforma aquí
estoy entrando yo a la plataforma voy a
salirme de mi cuenta para iniciar desde
un principio entonces cuando ustedes
entran a la plataforma por primera vez
ustedes llegan a esta pantalla donde
dice estudiantes se inician aquí
maestros se inician aquí papás inician
aquí nosotros como vamos a iniciar con
maestros nosotros vamos a hacer clic en
maestros se inician aquí para abrir una
cuenta así es que no tiene ninguna
cuenta todavía estos son los pasos que
tienen que seguir entonces vamos a
siempre les sugiero es sugerencia
registrarse con su correo electrónico en
lugar de con facebook o con google y
luego perdemos la cuenta de facebook
etcétera no entonces vamos a hacer clic
en regístrate con tu correo electrónico
aquí vamos a poner ya sea su correo
personal o bien el correo de la
institución si ustedes tienen un correo
por parte de su institución de su
escuela yo les sugiero que utilicen ese
siempre entonces si no lo tienen si no
tienen un correo por parte del escuela o
de la institución donde trabajan pueden
usar el suyo y aquí van a poner su
nombre voy a poner por ejemplo
mi correo
voy a poner mi nombre
con el apellido y le voy a dar voy a
poner una contraseña traten siempre de
que sea una contraseña fácil de recordar
anoté la debe ser de 8 caracteres
incluyan números letras y símbolos
etcétera no entonces yo voy a poner mi
password y automáticamente si notan se
activa el botón de regístrate ustedes
una vez que tengan listo de la
información le van a dar clic en
regístrate para que les crear su cuenta
nueva si yo en este caso ya tengo una
cuenta así que no voy a dar con este
correo ya no voy a dar clic en
regístrate pero sigan estos sencillos
pasos
para llenar su correo electrónico la
información que les piden de nombre
apellido y crear su contraseña y le dan
clic en regístrate aquellos que ya
tienen una cuenta con khan academy vamos
a hacer click en iniciar sesión
poner el correo electrónico con el que
nos registramos
y vamos a poner la contraseña que usamos
para registrarnos
automáticamente hacemos click en iniciar
sesión en traer de lleno a la plataforma
muchos de ustedes cuando entremos a la
plataforma aquí ustedes no van a tener
nada no los que están entrando por
primera vez aquí ustedes no van a
encontrar nada porque porque no han
creado ninguna clase no cuando ya
empiezan a tener ya crear sus clases
ustedes van a tener aquí todas sus
clases en listadas ok y acá vamos a ver
un botón que dice agregar una clase
a quien agregar una clase con que
hagamos clic en agregar una clase vamos
a poder crear nuestra primera clase en
el caso de que sea la primera vez que
están entrando a khan academy adrianita
quieres continuar con esta parte
y no voy a dejar de compartir mi
mi pantalla y seguimos con con adrián a
enseñar visual juguete a ver si se meten
ustedes como profesores y todavía no se
han inscrito al campeonato lo que les va
a aparecer aquí es inscríbete al
campeonato si ustedes ya se inscribieron
lo que les va a aparecer es este banner
que dicen ya empezó el campeonato buque
el día de hoy arrancó el programa eso no
quiere decir que no puedan invitar a
otros compañeros o si no se han inscrito
no lo pueden hacer ahora lo pueden hacer
ahora mismo no pasa nada y éste si
ustedes quieren agregar una clase les
voy a mostrar cómo se hace este les van
a aparecer tres pasos el nombre de su
clase
digamos que ustedes tienen diversos
grupos o un grupo yo puedo poner este
grupo de segundo se esté secundaria
porcino y secundaria un poco pues con el
bachillerato lo que sea como se llame tu
grupo
y aquí te va aparecer todo el contenido
que aparece en khan academy el contenido
de kanata de mí les comento que es está
organizado por temas matemáticas o
ciencias de biología química física
ingeniería o por este gramos entonces si
un profesor da clases en primaria
secundaria o bachillerato puede dar pues
ya sea por tema por grado o por materia
no aquí también tenemos otro este tipo
de contenido que es muy interesante para
complementar ciertas este materias
este es un profesor de matemáticas lo
que les recomendamos es que le dé clic
aquí a donde dice el mundo de las
matemáticas porque éste abarca a todo el
contenido de matemáticas de khan academy
y el profesor puede hacer lo que se
llama remediación nos hace un alumno
está reservado en algún concepto y otro
está muy adelantado lo que puede hacer
es cómo agarrar diferente contenido para
diferente tipo de nivel de conocimiento
a sus alumnos entonces les voy a mostrar
lo que es nueva porque tenemos un nuevo
lo que no habían visto antes aquellos
que ya conocen la plataforma pues es
este nuevo tema que se llama mentalidad
de crecimiento entonces si ustedes son
profesores de humanidades o de ciencias
o de matemáticas no importa ustedes
pueden utilizar este contenido extra y
si lo pueden asignar a sus alumnos
cuando al hacer una clase como pueden
ver ya hicieron su grupo ya le pusieron
el nombre de la clase y ahora se van a
preguntar cómo agregar a mis alumnos lo
que pueden hacer es ya sea compartir un
código con sus alumnos y los alumnos
tienen que tener una cuenta de khan
academy para poder éste ingresar este
código o bien hay tres opciones que
pueden tener para agregar a sus alumnos
esta parte es muy importante porque
tenemos muchos profes inscritos pero les
falta agregar sus clases y creo que esto
es porque todavía no saben cómo agregar
a sus estudiantes les pueden si usan
ustedes la plataforma de de google y
ustedes manejan este tipo de sistema
para organizar sus clases
nuestra plataforma está pues en bonao
trabajar de manera in con mucha
sincronía con google entonces ustedes
pueden importar sus clases de google
classroom o si no simplemente le dan
click aquí y con una coma separan los
los diferentes medios de sus estudiantes
no entonces aquí como dice este este
ejemplo ustedes yo podría poner a ti
garcía si eso fuera su mail
para ti garcía
este dime si se pone a su correo y ya la
está invirtiendo utilizando a participar
en clase no ya cuando creas tu clase
pues pues ya sea encontrar ejercicios
asignarlos a tus estudiantes o compartir
pues ver la página de tu clase para ver
cómo va a cada uno no esté ver el
progreso de tus alumnos
no sé si quieras que les muestre algo
más para ti
creo que es importante que sepan cómo
agregar a sus alumnos ya sea este su
página principal cuando ustedes le dan
clic aquí les va a aparecer panel del
tutor cuando ustedes al clicar panel de
tutor lo que les va a aparecer es
precisamente esto este tienen aquí a sus
estudiantes
y pueden agregar a sus estudiantes a la
plataforma y usted ser los tutores
agregando pueden agregar ya sea con el
correo electrónico que es como yo lo
hice con estos estudiantes o yendo a sus
clases y aquí donde dice estudiantes
ustedes pueden ir agregando diferentes
personas a sus clases como les digo cada
vez que crean una clase se les va a
hacer un código único de su clase y lo
van a poder compartir ahí o bien dando
clic aquí y así siguiendo el mismo paso
o las mismas instrucciones que siguieron
cuando crearon su clase importando desde
google o enviando un correo electrónico
no sé si haya otra duda
como pueden ver el contenido por ejemplo
si tienen una clase que yo tengo una
clase aquí de matemáticas elementales
les puede asignar contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento lo que tengo
aquí es una clase de 1º de primaria y
cuando le doy aquí clic a esta parte les
va a aparecer éste editar cursos y ahí
pueden ustedes agregar nuevos cursos
bueno agregar nuevos materias yo agrega
mentalidad de crecimiento cuando ustedes
le dan click a mentalidad de crecimiento
los alumnos que están en su clase de
matemáticas elementales van a poder ver
ciertas
materias o contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento que ustedes van a poder
asignar aquí donde dice asignada yo
elijo los estudiantes a los cuales les
quiero dar este material específico ya
sea todos o algunos
no sé si quieras decir algo más para ti
excelente agrega muchísimas gracias
si quieres este continuó yo perfecto
gracias
ok
vamos a continuar entonces bueno como
les explicó ya
adriana esto es como crea en su clase
también lo tienen en la presentación
recuerden el paso 1 es hacer clic en el
botón de agregar una clase primero por
favor crean sus clases
tienen que crear primero sus clases y
después de inscribirse al campeonato
ahora otra parte importante es eliminar
también las clases que ya no están
usando entonces para crear una clase un
rápido repaso son básicamente 45 pasos
muy muy básicos hagan clic en agregar
una clase como les dijo adriana pongan
el nombre a su clase seleccionen de la
lista de de materias de cursos que
tenemos disponibles ya sea que lo hagan
por grado o por o por curso de
matemáticas o ciencias podemos hacer
biología química física etcétera
el siguiente es invitar a sus alumnos yo
la sugerencia que les hago siempre es a
través del código es lo más rápido lo
más efectivo aprovechen que tienen a sus
alumnos todos juntos en el salón de
clases y les dan el código de la clase
que lo ven siempre para cada clase que
ustedes crean van a tener un código
entonces pueden apuntar en letras bien
grandes en el pizarrón el código de la
clase pedirle a sus alumnos que vayan a
esta dirección de khan academy punto org
diagonal join y ahí les dicen pone el
código ponen el código se suman y en
cuestión de segundos se suman a su clase
no también como les comentó adriana
pueden hacerlo a través de correo
electrónico a mí esta opción de repente
no me encanta porque si me ha pasado que
semanas después todavía sigo percibiendo
persiguiendo perdón alumnos para que se
sumen a mi clase una vez que ya invitan
a sus alumnos ya ya su clase ha sido
creada y ya podemos comenzar a explorar
y asignar el contenido del curso que
seleccionamos así de sencillo
como elimino clases antiguas entonces
para eliminar clases antiguas lo primero
que tengo que hacer es ir a la clase que
quiero eliminar hacer clic en la clase
que quiero eliminar una vez que se abre
la clase entro a configuración y
automáticamente me da la opción de
eliminar esta clase porque es importante
profesores que eliminemos las clases con
las que ya no estamos trabajando porque
cuando ustedes se inscriben al
campeonato automáticamente todas las
clases que ustedes tienen activas todas
las clases que ustedes han creado van a
entrar automáticamente en campeonato
entonces si yo ya tengo clases de años
anteriores donde ya no que ya no estoy
trabajando con ellas donde ya no tengo
alumnos oa mis alumnos ya está salieron
de la escuela o lo que sea esas clases
van a quedar incluidas sino las borramos
entonces es un paso importante que
debemos seguir es primero borrar
nuestras clases al igual que crear las
nuevas no entonces
en la plataforma les voy a enseñar qué
sencillo es no si yo me voy aquí a
página el tutor yo selecciono la clase
que quiero borrar vamos a suponer que
sea esta clase entro a la clase y aquí
siempre voy a tener este menú en todas
mis clases en todas va a aparecer
contenido tareas avance actividad lista
y configuración le hago clic en
configuración y automáticamente me
aparece todo este menú en donde yo puedo
cambiar de curso o asignar más como les
dijo adriana yo puedo asignar más de un
curso en mi clase puede a lo mejor estar
viendo pre algebra hay fundamentos de
álgebra o primero de secundaria y
segundo de secundaria dependiendo y
puedo también cambiar el nombre de mi
clase etcétera aquí en esta lista botón
de configuración me da la opción de
eliminar esta clase le hago clic me
pregunta está seguro que quieres
eliminar esta clase yo le digo ok y
automáticamente en cuestión de menos de
un minuto la clase se elimina
y entonces es muy sencillo es un paso
muy sencillo y muy importante de hacer y
de seguir para que no se sumen clases
que ya están inactivas o que ya están
digamos pues muertas
entonces háganlo por favor antes de
crear sus clases y bueno ya tengo mis
clases creadas ya eliminé clases que
siguen o que queden parte importante
sigue como para poder yo continuar al
campeonato no entonces una vez que ya
tengo mis clases creadas ya mis alumnos
invitados ya lo que lo que toca hacer lo
que me corresponde es asignar contenido
a mis estudiantes ahora que tengo yo que
hacer para que mis alumnos tengan éxito
en campeonato debemos asignar mínimo
tres recursos por semana esto viene
representando más o menos una media hora
de práctica de los jóvenes o sea la
semana no es nada de verdad créanme que
los jóvenes acaban practicando más
porque la plataforma los engancha
los atrapa los
y practicar mucho más que eso pero
nuestro mínimo es asignar tres recursos
cualesquiera que sean y ahorita vamos a
ver con qué recursos cuento este por
semana a cada uno de mis alumnos para
tener éxito en campeonato para que
nuestra clase realmente logre los
objetivos del campeonato el 100 por
ciento de nuestros alumnos deben cumplir
con estas tres tareas digamos semanales
porque hacemos esto porque sabemos y
todos somos docentes
sabemos que hay alumnos que bueno
inmediatamente cumplirán con la tarea y
los requisitos y bueno van a ser los más
este responsables pero también tenemos
alumnos que son un poquito más
desidiosos que no lo quieren hacer que
les da flojera etcétera pero al hacerlos
responsables también del éxito del grupo
pues no se van a tener que poner las
pilas se van a tener que trabajar a la
par de sus compañeros es por eso que
gana cullen exige el 100 por ciento de
la participación de todos los alumnos
qué quiere decir
esto que si yo tengo 20 alumnos en mi
clase y voy a asignar 3 recursos a cada
uno de ellos
en total debieran ser 60 recursos en el
momento en que entren los 60 recursos se
va a lograr el 100% de los en ese mes en
esa clase no en ese grupo entonces es
por eso que es importante que los
motivamos que les hagamos saber la
importancia que tienen cada uno de ellos
en el logro y en el éxito de este
programa oye para ti hay una meta que
está preguntando o sea ella lo que hizo
es mandarle un correo electrónico a sus
alumnos pero no han respondido a la
invitación como la haces tú para que los
alumnos se despierten digite cáceres
pues nuevamente yo lo que aconsejo es
cuando la siguiente vez que la maestra
tenga a todos sus alumnos en clase que
apunten el pizarrón khan academy punto
or diagonal point
y el código de la clase y decirles sumes
a la clase ahorita no y en ese desde su
celular lo pueden hacer no también si
tienen no pueden llevarlos al salón de
cómputo de la escuela y aprovechar ese
tiempo con ellos para hacerlo porque
exactamente eso me ha pasado a mí y no
hay manera de obligarlos porque muchos
de ellos no checan su correo no lo
revisan diario o no tienen acceso a él
etcétera entonces se me ha pasado de
verdad que dos meses después sigo
persiguiendo alumnos no entonces lo más
efectivo y eficiente es a través del
código eso es lo que ellos le surgieron
a la maestra
o bien también que estando en el salón
de clase a través de sus celulares
cetera les pida que vayan a su correo y
que contesten su invitación sí ya la
envió obligarlos a que estando ahí en
clase no revisen su correo hasta darle
cinco minutos para que revisen el correo
y entren a la clase
ok continuamos otros como asigno
contenido a estos 3 contenidos a mis
estudiantes ok vamos a para esto me voy
a salir de la plataforma recuerden antes
que nada que este es al haber realmente
la selección de cursos que nos da can
academia en mexico es impresionante es
así está muy apegada a lo que son
nuestros requerimientos a lo que son
los requerimientos también de la sed
entonces si si viene siendo una
plataforma que nos va a facilitar mucho
la enseñanza de las matemáticas y la
ciencia entonces cómo así que número que
pueda asignar antes que nada no ustedes
pueden asignar vídeos o sacan academy
empezó así no con un menú en enorme de
vídeos para que los chicos pudieran
entender cómo se hacía algo hoy día
están a una gran cantidad de ellos en
español son vídeos cortos concisos
claros de verdad muy fáciles de entender
también tenemos ya artículos no hay cada
vez se van sumando más artículos tenemos
un gran número de artículos ya en
español pero se siguen sumando nos
seguimos agregando cada vez más tenemos
artículos que pueden servir para repasar
digamos a al final de una unidad se
puede repasar el contenido de la unidad
antes de un examen etcétera entonces
podemos asignar artículos que también
son cortos muy claros
y también podemos asignar ejercicios
éstos generalmente esto es algo nuevo
que me encanta en khan academy porque
antes asignaba siete ejercicios digamos
de un grupo grande de ejercicios
generalmente aquí nos dice no hay 20
preguntas y de esas 20 preguntas se le
van a hacer a los alumnos 7 preguntas se
les va a mandar 7 ejercicios antes a
todos se les mandaban los mismos 7
ejercicios sólo nos dan la opción de ya
sea a pedir que le manden a todos
nuestros alumnos los mismos ejercicios o
pedir que cada uno reciba diferentes y
es que nos preocupa la parte de que
copien o no de que se copien los
resultados entonces aquí podemos ya
tener esta opción
y también podemos asignar que esto
también es nuevo y me encanta podemos
asignar una especie como de evaluaciones
cortas formativas cuestionarios no en
donde a los chicos se les hacen cinco
preguntas y es aquí cuando ellos porque
esto es generalmente lo porque están
después de haber hecho cierto número de
ejercicios de algún concepto entonces
agrupan tres o cuatro de los conceptos
que los chicos han venido practicando y
les hacen una pequeña evaluación de
cinco preguntas y es aquí donde ellos
ganan más puntaje donde ellos van
subiendo más de niveles no entonces aquí
si lo contestan bien dice bueno puedes
obtener hasta 480 puntos puedes subir a
tal nivel etcétera no entonces hoy día
podemos asignar cuestionarios después de
no sé de que nuestros chicos han estado
practicando ciertos conceptos podemos
decirles ok ahora hagan estaba la
pequeña evaluación formativa y también
tenemos pruebas de unidad en estas
pruebas de unidad sacan academy ya
dividió el contenido en un
es que eso también es nuevo y es
maravilloso porque al final de cada
unidad nosotros ya podemos asignar un
examen de unidad una prueba de unidad no
aquí son más largas y obviamente
incluyen preguntas de todos los
conceptos de todas las habilidades que
los alumnos aprendieron en esa unidad
entonces aquí son más largas son 16
preguntas y aquí están bien si lo
contestan bien donde suben de nivel
donde ganan más puntos digamos dentro de
no de lo que viene siendo su curso
etcétera no entonces podemos asignar
pruebas de unidad y
les voy a poner este pequeño vídeo
y hoy
su ser
[Música]
o
ahora sí
ok cómo lo hacemos entonces me voy a
regresar aquí a la plataforma entonces
voy a entrar a una clase que yo acabo de
crear aquí de campeonato 2018 les voy a
pedir que si ustedes tienen su
dispositivo
perdón vamos a parar aquí este es el
reactivo de primera pago está ok y vamos
entonces como les decía
les voy a pedir que aquellos que tienen
su dispositivo en la mano se unan a mi
clase también para esto esto es
importante porque es es necesario que
ustedes conozcan cuál es la visión
también del alumno no como como los
alumnos van a percibir esta plataforma
como podemos guiarlos para que sepan
cómo contestar a los recursos cómo
acceder a sus recursos etcétera
entonces yo aquí en lista voy a poner
agregar nuevos estudiantes y les voy
ellos que tienen su dispositivo en la
mano que vayan en una ventana nueva van
a teclear tanaka ne de mi punto por
diagonal join ok lo voy a hacer clic ahí
y se les va a abrir esta ventana no en
donde aquí en esta parte van a poner el
código
el código que ustedes les van a dar
entonces van a poner
el código de j
2 x efe todo en mayúscula entonces lo
pueden colocar en el pizarrón o incluso
les sugiero hacer un póster con el
canaca de mi doctor diagonal joint y el
código abajo y dejarlo en un lugar
visible de su clase para aquellos
alumnos que que se suman a su clase más
adelante siempre tengan visible no cómo
pueden unirse a su clase decana caen
pegan ahí el código así de sencillo y
hacen clic en únete a la clase
automáticamente le dice has ingresado
con éxito a la clase en cuestión de un
par de segundos no entonces es por eso
que yo sugiero que no que utilicen este
método que es el más rápido el más
efectivo
les voy a dar unos minutos para aquellos
que tienen su dispositivo se sumen por
favor
también pueden imprimir las
instrucciones éstas todavía no las
tenemos en español pero si desean pueden
imprimirlo para darle una porción a cada
alumno para que lo pegue en su en su
cuaderno de matemáticas con el código de
la clase etcétera para que sepan cómo
entrar siempre o como les digo la opción
del póster siempre también es muy
efectiva
adriana si puedes también tus sumarte
por favor
entonces aquí tengo me dice actualizar
tareas aquí tiene cinco nuevos
estudiantes y cinco nuevos estudiantes
en tu clase no entonces bienvenidos
héctor ayer juan carlos mis laura y
bueno si si quieren seguir sumando
nuevamente les doy aquí el código el
código siempre va a aparecer aquí al
lado de su clase el código de la clase
está del lado superior a derecho aquí
tienen el código no entonces sigan se
suma no y entonces yo como maestro que
ya tengo mi lista está como les digo es
el menú que va a aparecer en todas mis
clases cuando yo hago clic en contenido
automáticamente se va a desplegar todo
el contenido de mi clase yo en este en
este curso en esta clase que creé
seleccione dos cursos pre álgebra y
fundamentos de álgebra recuerden que
siempre tengo la opción de agregar más o
de quitar si yo decido que nada más va a
ser pre algebra lo quito si decido que
va a ser fundamentos de álgebra y argeo
grados o o fundamentos de la geometría
básica por ejemplo entonces yo le puedo
dar a guardar y automáticamente al hacer
clic aquí me está diciendo que tengo
nuevos alumnos
aquí automáticamente tengo los cursos
que agregue o que asigne para esta clase
entonces su equipo de ciro cake este
estoy empezando el año escolar voy a
comenzar con propiedades aritméticas
factores múltiples etcétera entonces
fíjense aquí como todo lo que yo tengo
tengo valor posición al redondear
números naturales y aquí al final tengo
ver vista de un cuestionario que viene
siendo una evaluación digamos corta de
lo que los alumnos han visto hasta ahora
orden de las apenas operaciones
propiedades aritméticas otro
cuestionario ya que al final no puedo
tener la prueba de la unidad no entonces
este primer esta primera unidad que
corresponde a propiedades aritméticas al
final puedo asignar también una prueba
de unidad lo que aquí me dicen que son
11 preguntas etc entonces si yo hago por
ejemplo en factores y múltiples
no vamos para carrera para propiedades
aritméticas / yo digo valor posicional
aquí tengo en valor posicional
para ese concepto fíjese todos los
recursos que yo puedo asignar tengo
puedo comenzar con un vídeo de dos
minutos
tengo un ejercicio de siete preguntas
tengo otro vídeo otro ejercicio otro
vídeo etcétera nosotros aquí puedo
revisar cuáles son para este valor
posicional para aprender ese tema
digamos ese esa vida qué recursos tengo
no entonces yo puedo asignar vamos a
suponer que yo quiero ver de qué se
trata este vídeo puedo ver el vídeo ver
percibir cómo el alumno lo va a ver
ok si es un vídeo que yo estoy de
acuerdo que siento que está para el
nivel de mis alumnos lo seleccionó
automáticamente se enciende el botón de
asignar uno yo aquí digo que el
ejercicio vamos a ver de qué tratan
estos ejercicios no entonces aquí me
dice bueno tienes 20 diferentes
preguntas tus alumnos van a recibir
solamente 7
estas 20 ok entonces yo lo puedo revisar
decir ok está bien desde acuerdo al
nivel oa lo que vimos en clase a lo que
repasamos en clase
lo voy a seleccionar recuerden que son
tres recursos por semana los que tenemos
que asignar entonces me voy a ir más
para abajo voy a ver ok
escriben números naturales en extensión
notación extendida puedo nuevamente
hasta hacer clic en vista previa para
ver qué es lo que mis alumnos van a ver
cómo lo van a recibir no si lo hago
todavía clic aquí en vista del alumno
los alumnos lo van a ver así ellos van a
tener sus siete problemas a medida que
ellos van contestando si van recibiendo
retroalimentación etcétera entonces lo
voy a cerrar y vamos a seleccionar esos
ejercicios automáticamente aquí ya me
dice estás asignando tres ejercicios
una vez que yo ya lo seleccione puedo
decir hacer clic en asignar y aquí está
la maravilla no porque aquí yo puedo
seleccionar lo que les decía así yo
quiero que cada estudiante trabaje con
un conjunto aleatorio de preguntas si me
preocupa que copien que se compartan las
respuestas etcétera puedo seleccionar
esta opción si al contrario quiere
uniformar mis respuestas ver cómo cómo
responde en el centro y poder realmente
hacer una comparación todos los alumnos
trabajan con el mismo conjunto de
preguntas esto ya depende del maestro
aquí puedo asignarlo si yo tengo tres
clases de tercero de secundaria o dos de
segundo etcétera yo desde aquí puedo
asignar la a todas mis clases o puedo
asignar la solamente a la clase que me
interesa no estos en este caso es la
clase de campeonato
y aquí también este este punto es muy
importante maestros porque aquí podemos
nosotros diferenciar de una manera súper
sencilla o sea para nosotros y yo
lo que digo como docentes una vez que
empiezan las clases nuestra vida se
vuelve una locura no tenemos tiempo para
nada y este y a veces nos falta tiempo
para lo más importante que es dar clases
no hay realmente ajustarnos a las
necesidades de nuestros alumnos entonces
diferenciar dentro del salón de clases
viene siendo una tarea faraónica sin
embargo cada camino los hacen muy
sencillo porque yo desde aquí puedo
hacer clic y decir ok esta parte esta
primera unidad realmente muchos de mis
alumnos la recuerdan bien porque viene
siendo un repaso del año anterior pero
puedo seleccionar aquí aquellos que
únicamente considero yo que tienen que
practicar esta unidad porque a lo mejor
hice una pequeña evaluación de inicio de
curso y noto que estos alumnos necesitan
practicarlo entonces puedo asignarlo
únicamente a esos alumnos o bien
recuerden que para campeonato
necesitamos enviarle los recursos a
todos entonces yo aquí selecciono
a todos y asigno ok automáticamente
nuestros alumnos van a recibir un correo
y en su página de alumnos que ahorita lo
vamos a ver ellos van a recibir estas
tareas ahora que otra cosa puedo hacer
yo también puedo si tengo tiempo porque
a veces se da el caso que tenemos un
poquito más de tiempo yo puedo decir que
quiero ver
no vamos a cerrar aquí valor posicional
y yo puedo decir ok orden de operaciones
esto es algo que yo yo como maestro
planeo ver a la mejor en dos semanas
entonces yo desde ahorita no puedo decir
ok
quiero ver esto de introducción es un
vídeo no
está interesante está corto está conciso
está muy claro entonces lo seleccionó
sin orden de introducción aquí por
ejemplo tengo otro vídeo no que puedo
también asignarlo si me interesa y aquí
tengo un ejercicio no voy a ver cómo
está ese ejercicio nuevamente como lo ve
el alumno y si me interesa y está de
acuerdo lo seleccionó y puedo
seleccionar estos tres pueden que
siempre son tres recursos ahora yo
nuevamente hago clic en asignar y aquí
nuevamente seleccionó en mi clase
nuevamente selección a todos los alumnos
puedo hasta ponerle una fecha límite
recuerden que esto es por semana pues yo
quiero que me lo contesten antes del 14
y a qué hora no no sé si mi clases a las
a las 11 de la mañana etcétera puedo
poner la hora
ok ahora como esto yo planeo verlo en
dos semanas no ahorita yo en lugar de
hacer clic en asignar puedo hacer clic
en guardar y asignar más tarde ok
entonces como sé en dónde está en
nuestras tareas yo me voy aquí a tareas
hago clic en tareas y aquí en tareas
bueno esta parte también es nueva esta
parte es muy interesante ahorita la
vamos a ver porque me puedes decir la
tarea por alumno a que me está alistando
a todos mis alumnos y las diferentes
tareas que tienen asignadas o puedo
poner por tarea
aquí por me dice que me está diciendo
que tengo cinco nuevos estudiantes los
actualizo ok aquí me dice ok todas estas
son las tareas que yo le asignado a esta
clase ok y aquí me dice aquí por ejemplo
tengo un alumno
y ha completado la tarea y aquí
automáticamente me dice 1p a reporte
entonces aquí me dice todas las tareas
que yo asignado cuando las asigne o si
cuando cuando vencen cuando se asignaron
quienes las han completado y desde aquí
puedo ya sea editar la tarea si le
quiero cambiar la fecha de entrega o
copiar la tarea si quiero volver a crear
el mismo no esté quiero mandar el mismo
recurso entonces aquí si yo le hago aquí
en activa están todas las tareas activas
si yo le hago clic en guardadas están
todas las tareas que yo creé pero las
guarde para asignar más adelante no
porque esto lo voy a asignar a la mejor
en la semana 2 de campeonato en la
semana 3 cuando estoy lista únicamente
seleccionó la tarea y hago clic en
asignar y automáticamente
la tarea pasa a la sección de tareas
activas entonces esto nos permite
organizarnos no de una mejor manera
cuando tenemos un poquito de tiempo
podemos hacer esto de manera que podamos
ir planeando
las clases asignando a nuestros recursos
con anticipación no hay tenerlas
guardadas he llegado el momento las
asignamos
ahora les voy a pedir a todos por favor
vamos a cuando ustedes tienen aquí su
página digamos su curso cuando yo hago
clic aquí están acá de mí siempre me va
a llevar a mi página de inicio como
selecciono cual quiero que sea mi página
de inicio en cada academia y para
aquellos que no lo saben lo que es la
primera vez que entran a khan academy yo
en canadá ni puedo tener dos roles puedo
ser un alumno pero también puede ser un
maestro o sea yo puedo ser maestro y
tener mis clases en cierta institución
pero quizá también sea un alumno y
tomando una clase a lo mejor de cálculo
avanzado de geometría avanzada con algún
colega o en algún otro lugar
y entonces puedo también ser un alumno
como cambió este rol en khan academy yo
no necesito crear una cuenta como alumno
y otra cuenta como maestro puedo crear
una sola cuenta nada más cambiar mi rol
dentro de la misma cuenta como lo hago
aquí arriba ustedes tienen su nombre ok
si yo hago clic en el nombre aquí
automáticamente me dice página de inicio
del aprendizaje
quiere decir estos aprendizajes que yo
soy alumno entonces si yo hago clic aquí
automáticamente me va a llevar a mi
página de alumno yo como alumno sí y
aquí está mis medallas las tareas que
tengo si yo hago clic aquí en tareas me
dice qué tareas y de qué clase tengo
cuando vencen a qué horas y desde aquí
yo puedo empezar mi tarea esto es como
lo van a ver sus alumnos esta es la
versión de alumnos no todos los alumnos
aquí van a poder ver su perfil sus
medallas que han ganado el avance que
tienen los proyectos los tutores que
tiene porque a lo mejor tienen una clase
biología una clase de álgebra una clase
de física dentro de khan academy no
entonces pueden tener varios tutores
entonces aquí el alumno ve de qué clase
no cuando vence su tarea que es su tarea
y desde aquí pueden hacer clic y
comenzar si yo hago clic nuevamente en
mi nombre en la parte superior puede
decir bm vete a la al panel de tutor ya
aquí es donde yo entro a mitad
como un maestro ok entonces yo aquí
entró como maestro y aquí es donde yo
veo enlistadas mis clases etc como
asigno cual quiero que sea mi página
base vaya a mi página a la que siempre
que haga clic aquí en el logo me lleve
entonces vuelvan a hacer clic en su
nombre y se van a ir a configuración
en configuración les voy a pedir que
aquí van ir hasta abajo aquí ustedes
pueden cambiar su nombre etcétera
etcétera pueden conectar con google
pueden conectar con facebook etcétera
pero vámonos hasta acá abajo y aquí en
roles asegúrense de que estén las dos
palomeadas tanto el estudiante como
maestro tienen que estar las dos
palomeadas estudiante y maestro si son
padres de familia que están abriendo una
clase para sus hijos puede también ser
esa opción y aquí es donde ustedes van a
elegir su página de inicio cuál quieren
que sea si como estudiantes como padres
o como tutores yo les sugiero que
siempre seleccionen como tutor y van a
hacer clic en guardar cambios
asegúrense que tengan aquí ubicación
méxico ciudad de méxico que debiera
estar así y aquí el día que quieran
eliminar su cuenta también lo pueden
hacer desde acá no entonces qué quiere
decir con esto que siempre que yo haga
clic en el logo me va a llevar a mi
página de inicio que yo seleccione que
fuera mi página como tutor
automáticamente me va a llevar a este
entonces les voy a pedir ahorita que
hagan clic aquí en su nombre y se van a
ir a su página de aprendizaje como como
alumnos todos los que están ahorita en
mi clase hagan clic en el nombre hagan
clic en inicio del aprendizaje y aquí
van a ver sus tareas la clase a la que
se apuntaron conmigo se llama campeonato
2018 les voy a pedir a la tarea que me
hagan la tarea de pruebas de
divisibilidad hagan clic en pruebas de
divisibilidad se les va a abrir esta
tarea y les voy a pedir que me contesten
las siete preguntas les va a dar unos
minutitos para que lo hagan por favor
y quiero que noten lo importante por
ejemplo aquí yo estoy contestando un
cuestionario una pequeña evaluación que
dice bueno empezar prueba de
prueba de unidad bueno esta es una
prueba perdón una prueba de unidad
entonces inicia el cuestionario van a
estar evaluando tres diferentes
conceptos entonces aquí me dice cuál de
los siguientes números es un múltiplo de
8 entonces automáticamente siempre los
alumnos van a recibir retroalimentación
buen trabajo continúa avanzando y
siempre les va a dar este
obviamente retroalimentación positiva no
si es esto divisible entre entre 9
entonces aún cuando se equivocan digamos
vamos a poner vamos a ponerle que si
siempre van a estar recibiendo
y retroalimentación positiva no entonces
buen trabajo lo lograste eh una más
entonces vamos a poner la cometerá que
un error yo le pongo no y me dice vuelve
a intentarlo inténtalo y siempre el
alumno va a tener opción de recurrir a
ayuda no y esto es muy importante
profesores porque nosotros damos
contenido en clase explicamos un
concepto la mayoría de los chicos dicen
sí sí entendí perfecto pero luego van a
su casa tratan de resolverlos solos y no
pueden y es ahí donde viene la
frustración y es ahí donde viene la
desmotivación y este pensamiento
espantoso que tienen sobre las
matemáticas de que yo no puedo esto no
es para mí porque finalmente cuando nos
necesitan a nosotros como profesores
nosotros no estamos presentes entonces a
mí khan academy me encanta porque vienen
siendo como un tutor personalizado les
da a los jóvenes la opción de recurrir a
vídeos no pueden aquí tener un vídeo
pueden incluso hasta acceder no aún a
una tipa alguna no algún consejo de cómo
resolver este problema que le dice no
cualquier número par es divisible entre
entonces ya que el alumno ve el vídeo
los los tips que les que le da khan
academy para resolver el problema
contesta correctamente y se mejorar tu
respuesta sigue practicando no entonces
esta parte a mí me encanta porque siento
que el alumno va ganando confianza y la
plataforma se va acomodando a las
necesidades del alumno no cosa que que
para nosotros digo hacemos nuestro mejor
esfuerzo por hacerlo pero a veces no
nuevamente por la cantidad de alumnos
que tenemos no podemos no entonces aquí
el alumno puede recurrir a esa ayuda
extra no no solamente tener a sus
profesores en clase sino también a khan
academy en casa
y puede hacerlo a su propio ritmo no a
su propia velocidad recurriendo a
cuantas a cuantos recursos él necesite
no también también escribiremos a mí por
ejemplo ahorita que me pusiste la tarea
ley 6 y la verdad es que no me acordaba
la regla de divisibilidad del número 4 y
me acordaba y tenía unas pistas
entonces si tú que también está padre
porque no podemos esperar que nuestra
memoria sea perfecta pero si podemos
esperar tener recursos que nos ayuden a
guardarnos y ahorita había algo hoy y ya
tengo como una regla que me va ayudar a
recordar cómo dividir no entonces siento
que eso también está interesante de khan
academy que si no quieres saber la
respuesta inmediatamente
khan academy te da esto que se llama
pistas y me parece excelente porque no
está la respuesta inmediatamente
excelente si así esto entonces yo creo
que los alumnos de verdad que es un
ganar ganar tanto como maestro un alumno
de verdad se los digo diego fi antes de
trabajar para detective y maestras
matemáticas por casi 15 años matemáticas
y ciencias y kick and academy siempre
fue de verdad mi mano derecha o sea que
les puedo decir un apoyo enorme jamás
sentí como que fuera un rival lo que me
fuera a quitar mi trabajo mi chamba al
contrario fue un apoyo enorme y de
verdad y mucho
y se os anote no el cambio en muchos de
mis alumnos
con respecto a las matemáticas como que
su actitud ante las matemáticas cambió
le decimos a gustar a descubrir que no
eran tan malos no entonces esto es lo
que tenemos que lograr en nuestros
alumnos
si quieren contestar otro más no pueden
hacer este por ejemplo no sé factores
múltiples o hagan alguna evaluación les
va a pedir que contestan otro el que
ustedes quieran de las tareas que tienen
asignadas para que yo les puede enseñar
cuáles son los reportes a los que
tenemos acceso
contesten uno más puede ser un vídeo
puede ser este otro ejercicio puede ser
uno de los juicios o evaluaciones o por
qué no hacer hasta el el examen de
unidad no entonces les voy a dar unos
minutitos
y yo me va a regresar mientras a mi
página como tutor voy a entrar a la
clase
en donde ya tengo ahorita
seis nuevos al
analicia reptiliano profe norma mis
labra a miguel ángel a leonor juan
carlos jorge manzano hair héctor héctor
larios amor a cinthia celia antonio alma
gracias por estar aquí gracias por
unirse a la clase
a ver cintia dice que no saben cómo ver
tu tarea es perfecto sin tienen mira te
vas a ir aquí a tu nombre vas a hacer
clic aquí en la parte superior derecha
vas a hacer clic y aquí va desde este
este menú y dice página del inicio del
aprendizaje vas a hacer clic ahí porque
eso te va a llevar a tu página como rol
como un alumno digamos entonces
automáticamente se te va a abrir está
ahí tiene tu nombre y aquí tú eres a un
alumno entonces te vas a ir a tareas
y ahí automáticamente te van a aparecer
las tareas que yo te asignen esta clase
tu clase que debe ser campeonato 2018 y
la fecha límite hora límite de entrega y
aquí está automáticamente el botón de
empezar y haces clic en empezar y ya sea
sea el vídeo o sea un ejercicio ya
tienes acceso a ver el vídeo oa
contestar tus ejercicios
listo
ahora cómo puedo yo como maestro ver las
tareas que voy recibiendo de mis alumnos
no yo estoy nuevamente aquí en mi clase
no tengo aquí todo mi contenido etcétera
voy a hacer mi todo mi menú ya revisamos
contenido recuerden que desde ahí voy a
asignar mis tres recursos y si yo hago
clic aquí en tareas
ok aquí automáticamente me dice bueno
por alumno o por tarea recuerden que
aquí en tarea puedo ver mis tareas
activas mis tareas guardadas que estén
guardadas para asignar más adelante ok
desde aquí también puedo ir viendo por
ejemplo aquí pruebas de divisiva
visibilidad seis de mis alumnos 6 de 14
ya la contestaron no ahora si yo hago
clic aquí en por alumno
esto es nuevo y es muy interesante
porque yo aquí automáticamente fíjense
lo que me da me dice ok de esta tarea
pruebas de divisibilidad estos son los
alumnos que la han contestado y estas
son sus calificaciones
entonces me da una tarea y me hace una
idea inmediata desde mis alumnos en mi
clase entendieron o no este concepto no
que voy a hacer yo con esta información
porque recuerden que esta información en
tiempo real maestros o sea los chicos
los están contestando en su casa y
ustedes lo están viendo esa misma noche
en en casa también no entonces ya no es
de que extendemos la hoja de trabajo el
chico se lo lleva lo regresa al
siguiente día me lo llevo a mi casa lo
corrijo y cinco días después si bien nos
va ahí si tenemos tiempo los alumnos
están recibiendo sus resultados o
retroalimentación aquí es de inmediato
los alumnos contestan y automáticamente
se quien entendió o no o quién necesita
repasar más este concepto entonces qué
voy a hacer yo con esta información pues
al siguiente día voy a dividir mi clase
a la mejor
de los que se sacaron de 86 para arriba
les voy a dar una actividad más
significativa más diferente más lo que
requiera de más pensamiento crítico
etcétera o los pongo a practicar más en
can academy y aquellos en que se sacaron
menos lo que a lo mejor menos de 886 men
les voy a enseñar el concepto les voy a
los voy a poner también a practicar en
algo más básico pero aquí yo puedo
realmente diferenciar de una manera muy
sencilla no y darme una idea muy clara
de quién necesita o no practicar más
esta estabilidad no si yo hago clic en
el reporte automáticamente se abre el
reporte y me dice
de este estudiante no la preguntados que
la tuvo bien la tuvo mal la pregunta 1
no entonces también puedo ver a ver qué
tipo de preguntas son las que le está
costando más a mi alumno etcétera notas
a que me va diciendo cuál es la pregunta
en la que el alumno tuvo tuvo problemas
digamos entonces me va dando también una
idea muy clara no de nuevamente de cómo
están desempeñándose mis alumnos en
cierta tarea en cierta habilidad
me voy para atrás preguntas hasta aquí y
leonor
dice y dice que hago si no me aparece en
la pestaña tareas en mi perfil
en su perfil de maestro
a ver vamos a ver si nos podrías decir
si te inscribiste como maestro o como
estudiante porque eso afecta todo
obviamente no vas a ver las mismas cosas
como alumno o estudiante que como
profesor
sino con que se vaya a su nombre
nuevamente y haga panel del tutor ahí le
debe dar la al hacer panel de tutor
automáticamente le debe aparecer la
opción de agregar una clase etcétera y
puede agregar su clase
y entonces vamos a regresar aquí tengo
dos nuevos estudiantes siempre que van a
agregar los estudiantes a su clase les
va a ir notificando la plataforma que
tienen nuevos alumnos en clase yo hago
clic nuevamente voy a hacer clic aquí en
tareas cuando los alumnos vieron ya el
vídeo aparece nada más una palomita
obviamente ahí no hay una calificación
no pero aquí me va diciendo bueno por
ejemplo este estudiante está con 71 en
una tarea entonces yo aquí puedo revisar
la tarea ver en nuevamente en que le
falló no esté
entonces puedo incluso no volverá a
asignar nada más a ella oa todos desde
aquí el recurso otra vez nosotros
también puedo ver a ver tuvo problemas
en la pregunta uno tuvo problemas
no aquí puedo saber en qué preguntas se
atoró no tuvo problemas porque se sacó
un 72 etcétera y siempre
tener la opción de poder reasignar ese
ejercicio esa tarea
si luego ahorita tengo otra pregunta que
está por aquí
y es que dice los quiz ya están
predefinidos o los pueden diseñar ellos
no hasta ahorita no tenemos esa opción
los jueces tanto los juicios como los
exámenes están predefinidos o sea no nos
van dando por cada cierto número de
temas cierto número de conceptos es este
bien en la opción del quiz hasta ahorita
no se da la opción de definirlos
nosotros no digo nosotros podemos la
verdad es que hacer crisis de otra
manera no podemos organizarlos y
planeados este con otras herramientas
acá nos da finalmente una recopilación
de los de las habilidades que los
jóvenes han estado practicando no y leí
el tipo de ejercicios que han estado
practicando les hace algo muy similar la
verdad son son evaluaciones
fáciles de contestar cortas y muy
eficientes porque si nos dan una idea
muy clara de dónde está parado el alumno
y la otra pregunta es de perla cruz nos
dice que ella agregó estudiantes después
y asignó tareas o sea haciendo tareas
antes y después a nadar unos y unos
alumnos nuevos no les apareció en las
tareas les va a tener que tener las
tareas a esos nuevos es eso está muy
extraño porque normalmente cuando
actualizó si se fijan ahorita que me ha
estado apareciendo el letrerito de
tienes nuevos alumnos tienen nuevos
alumnos al hacer yo actualizar
automáticamente se actualiza
las tareas para esos nuevos alumnos que
están entrando no eso porque las tareas
tan asignadas a la clase
independientemente de a qué alumnos
están entonces yo les sugeriría que le
dieran ruiz fresh que le diera acá el
botoncito de refresh para que su clase
se se reajuste digamos si no se si no
saliera esta opción si no se le diera
que me sorprendería porque normalmente
es automático pues si yo le sugiero que
asigne esas esas tareas a esos alumnos
únicamente en el caso de que no se le
actualicen
y aquí tenemos también como le digo por
tarea también acá tenemos otro tipo de
si yo tengo aquí me voy de aquí ya no
por alumnos sino por tarea aquí al hacer
clic en ver reporte automáticamente
cuando yo llevo alumnos contestado se
activa este botón de ver reporte lo
puedo ver ok y aquí también nuevamente
me no me va diciendo de todos mis
estudiantes este no como cual éste cuál
fue su desarrollo dentro de éste no
dentro de esta tarea etcétera entonces
también nuevamente me da mucha
información básica no sobre el desempeño
del alumno en esta tarea
preguntas hasta aquí
a ver 20 arte ritmo
si a veces si no ven algo lo mejor es
que le den click a la flechita esa
composición semicírculo que es
actualizar porque obviamente tienen que
volver a cargar los datos por ejemplo si
se inscriben y no aparecen sus clases
denle refrescar balance de su cuenta y
se vuelven a mente y les van a aparecer
sus clases ya ya dentro no hay ningún
mensaje que te diga que ya están dentro
ya una vez que tú te inscribes al
campeonato automáticamente tus clases se
agregan exacto
aquí en la presentación van a poder ver
también por eso es importante que la
guarden porque aquí tienen también los
pasos uno por uno de cómo asignar sus
tres recursos semanales a su clase es
recuerden que pueden asignar desde
vídeos artículos sus juicios sus pruebas
de unidad de ejercicios etcétera aquí
les digo también cómo guardar sus tareas
para un futuro y cómo pueden acceder a
los reportes recuerden que tienen dos
opciones por alumno o por tarea no está
ahí está por tareas entonces aquí en la
presentación tienen
el resumen de todo esto que estamos
viendo recuerden que para entrar a su
asu
digamos rol como alumno siempre a través
de su nombre y seleccionar la opción de
aprendizaje no estos van a entrar ahí
automáticamente a sus tareas no y como
los alumnos van crean van completando
sus asignaturas como ven para el alumno
es súper súper fácil entonces el alumno
únicamente hace clic en empezar y
automáticamente tiene acceso ya a sus
ejercicios o al vídeo a lo que sea que
estamos asignando también ellos reciben
un correo electrónico y también desde
ese correo electrónico ellos pueden
entrar en el momento de que reciban el
correo lo abren ahí mismo está el botón
de empezar entonces no tienen que entrar
a la plataforma es a través de ahí hacen
clic en empezar tarea y automáticamente
se les abre la plataforma de khan
academy y pueden contestar su tarea
entonces está hecho de una manera que
los alumnos uno no no se les pase la
tarea no sala vean ya sea por su correo
ya saben en la plataforma y dos les les
da la una manera muy fácil para poder
acceder a estas tareas no no tienen que
hacer cinco clics sabemos que después
del segundo clic y a los perdimos
entonces lo hacen de una manera muy
efectiva para que el alumno no tenga que
batallar en encontrar las tareas
entonces
como completan las asignaturas los
alumnos para que el vídeo se considere
que lo vieron deben ver al menos el 90%
del vídeo y ahí ya les aparece como como
completado los artículos deben entrar al
artículo para leerlo y los ejercicios
deben terminar el grupo de siete
ejercicios cuando cuando les asignamos
ejercicios generalmente vienen en
bloques de 7
y aparecen en las asignaturas estas son
preguntas muy clásicas dentro de cada
camino porque acuérdense que khan
academy tiene esta maravillosa
posibilidad de que se le da a los chicos
a través de la fundación de carlos slim
de que puedan acceder a
a khan academy desde su celular sin
tener que utilizar sus datos y entonces
esto esto lo hace mucho más pues
atractivo para los jóvenes porque la
preocupación de ellos y de nosotros
todos es cuidar nuestros datos móviles
no entonces aquí ellos pueden utilizar
ahorita se las vamos a compartir para
que la compartan nada a su vez con sus
alumnos y ellos puedan ésta acceder a
caná academy sin tener que usar sus
datos entonces ellos
pueden también ver sus asignaturas en
sus tareas en las últimas versiones de
la app de khan academy tanto para
android como para algo veis un nuevo
alumno se integra mi clase como me
aseguro de que reciba la asignatura lo
que les comentaba no cuando llegó un
alumno nuevo entre la clase verás una
alerta selecciona actualizar
entonces siempre que entren nuevos
alumnos hagan clic en actualizar para
que el alumno reciba todas las tareas
que se habían enviado con anticipación
hay una calificación aprobatoria en los
ejercicios de khan academy ya que
es muy importante maestros porque un
alumno puede alcanzar 70 por ciento
y con eso se puede quedar muy contento
siempre hay que motivarlo a que vaya por
más no a que llegue al 100% etcétera el
70 por ciento dentro del can academy son
seis niveles los que los alumnos tienen
que alcanzar
y aquí el 70% cuenta como familiarizado
el alumno está familiarizado con el
concepto a medida que siguen practicando
y van subiendo de calificación y van
ganando más puntos el objetivo es que el
alumno llegue al nivel de dominio de que
domina ese concepto para llegar al nivel
de dominado necesita el 100% no entonces
a medida que practica y contesta quizais
y contesta exámenes unidad no donde
vengan incluidos ese concepto y el
alumno se desempeña bien entonces
aparece ya ese concepto como dominado no
entonces eso es lo que hay que motivar
entonces bueno ya vimos los los reportes
no perdón no los hemos visto me voy a
regresar aquí a la plataforma
vimos los reportes de tareas pero dentro
del menú este que yo tengo acá arriba si
yo hago clic en avance
si aquí me va a dar varias opciones aquí
yo tengo a todos los a mis alumnos si
recuerden que para participar en
campeonato sus clases deben tener un
mínimo de 10 alumnos necesitan tener más
alumnos a no más de 10 alumnos o más no
si no no entra dentro del canal de
campeonato entonces yo tengo aquí a mis
alumnos y fíjense aquí como aparecen las
diferentes barras que me quiere decir
esto cuando yo tengo una esto es algo
bueno increíble también es nuevo como
les decía campeón
khan academy lo que hizo fue dividir los
cursos en unidades no más o menos como
nosotros las tenemos divididos entonces
dice ok desde mi curso de pre algebra yo
tengo que cumplir cierto número de
puntajes aquí si se fijan abajo dice ok
para que un alumno se diga que cumplió
el 100% del curso de para algebra debe
cumplir con 25 mil 750 puntos al cumplir
con ese puntaje se va a decir podemos
decir el alumno completó con éxito el
100% del curso de pre álgebra entonces
aquí yo voy viendo por ejemplo aquí
llevo el 0 por ciento estoy empezando el
año escolar entonces aquí en el 0 por
ciento tengo a 14 estudiantes que
automáticamente al hacer clic en la
barra me muestra quiénes son esos 14
estudiantes que apenas están comenzando
digamos aquí tengo un estudiante así que
este soy yo
luego aquí en el 20% tengo a tres
estudiantes que ya llevan completado el
20% del curso qué quiere decir que hasta
la fecha ha cumplido 5 mil 150 puntos
tengo aquí a un estudiante a miguel
ángel okey tengo en el 40% con 10.300
puntos tengo en la mis laura y también
tengo con
perdón aquí a edith también dentro de
este porcentaje entonces qué es lo que
va vamos a ir viendo a medida que
transcurso el año vamos a ir viendo cómo
estas barras se van moviendo del cero
por ciento hacia el 100% y obviamente yo
si tengo alumnos a mí no sé en dentro de
tres meses en el 0 en el 20% voy a ir
moviendo a estos alumnos o motivándolos
para que vayan avanzando porque mi
objetivo es que al final del año si lo
único que yo va enseñando es crear
febrero lo que sea que mis alumnos todos
mis alumnos estén aquí no en el 100% y
que logren los 25 mil 750 puntos como
los van a lograr completando sus
exámenes de unidad completando sus
evaluaciones que es donde más puntaje
ganan y donde más suben de niveles
completando todo eso y practicando es
cómo van a llegar a lograr ese ese
puntaje
si yo cambio aquí del curso porque yo a
esta clase las m tres cursos vamos a ver
geometría básica en geometría básica
ok fíjense cómo cambió mi gráfica porque
porque yo no ha asignado muchas tareas
de geometría básica éstos tengo aquí a
17 alumnos
ok aquí a 4 y en el 20% tengo a uno a
mis laura si se fijan aquí aquí es
diferente aquí el puntaje para cumplir
el cien por ciento de este curso es de
doce mil 625 puntos nuevamente a medida
que yo voy a asignando mis tres recursos
sobre geometría básica pre álgebra
etcétera mis alumnos a medida que
practican y van dominando cada uno de
esos conceptos se van a ir moviendo a
través de esta gráfica hasta que lleguen
al cien por ciento ok entonces aquí me
da una idea perfecta de dónde está
parado cada uno de mis alumnos no dentro
de mi clase si me voy a trabajo me hice
por unidades entonces aquí me lo da por
alumnos me da una idea muy clara de mis
alumnos pero si me voy acá abajo me dice
ok ahora te lo voy a decir por unidades
en unidades la primera unidad que es
fundamentos de pre álgebra aquí me dice
ok
esta es el primer tema de la primera
unidad y aquí fíjense yo hago clic en
eso y me dice que me tienes a 14
estudiantes no para yo poder cumplir
esta unidad solamente esta unidad ya nos
está hablando el curso necesitan mis
alumnos 3100 puntos para decir pasaron
con éxito esta primera unidad no
necesitan cubrir este puntaje los
alumnos a medida que van practicando y
contestando sus evaluaciones etcétera y
el examen de unidad ellos van a llegar
acá no entonces aquí es donde les decía
que están los diferentes puntajes no han
comenzado aquí tengo 14 estudiantes que
no han comenzado con esta unidad tengo a
ser estudiantes con dificultad tengo
algunos ya con competente digamos tengo
a dos estudiantes que están ya como
competente y seis alumnos que ya
dominaron estabilidad de números
negativos en la recta numérica estas son
las diferentes habilidades que el alumno
debe debe cumplir digamos para
y cubrir la primera unidad no entonces
todos mis alumnos a medida que voy
practicando deben ir moviéndose hacia
acá desde no ha empezado hasta dominado
nosotros como veis son 1 2 3 4 5 niveles
en el que el alumno a medida que
nosotros asignemos nuestros tres
recursos se van a ir moviendo hasta
llegar a dominados y esto es igual con
cada unidad no como les digo aquí tienen
siete unidades simplemente para el curso
de pre algebra y en cada una va a hacer
lo mismo no yo a medida que haga clic
ahora esta es la unidad de expresiones
algebraicas aquí me va diciendo cómo se
van moviendo mis alumnos en la gráfica
tienen que cumplir mil puntos para
cumplir para tener 100% de esta segunda
unidad no hay aquí nuevamente me va
diciendo ahora qué puedo hacer yo yo
puedo hacer clic en eso
por ejemplo yo digo ok evaluación
evaluar expresiones con una sola
variable tengo quince alumnos que me han
practicado yo hago clic acá yo desde
aquí puedo asignarlo y pues quiero que
me lo asigne a todos porque quiero que
todo lo sigan practicando porque quiero
que lo dominen los que van en camino y
que lo practiquen los que no han
practicado nada y desde aquí lo puedo
también asignar entonces es muy sencillo
porque yo recurriendo aquí yo
automáticamente desde aquí puedo asignar
el recurso que quiero asignarles que
davis que noto que nadie ha practicado
entonces es otra manera de asignar pero
ya mucho más enfocado a las necesidades
no va a hacer los practicar aquéllos
habilidades o conceptos que los alumnos
no han practicado de que necesitan
dominar entonces eso es con cualquier no
por ejemplo sistemas de ecuaciones no
entonces puede ser con cualquiera
de estas no de estos conceptos de estas
habilidades yo qué puedo decir
resolución por medio de gráficas y sólo
puedo asignar a todos mis alumnos no
pero aquí yo puedo decir ok
miguelangel ya lo domino todo no
necesito asignárselo a miguel ángel
puedo seleccionar a todos y quitárselo a
miguel ángel etcétera nosotros
nuevamente me puedo adaptar a las
necesidades de mis alumnos
preguntas hasta acá
ok otro de otro reporte que yo tengo es
de tal pregunta este como pueden ver los
alumnos la plataforma sin datos tienen
que acceder a una liga especial
ahorita se la damos es la de éste
en ese punto 0 con z exacto tanaka en mi
pulgar puedes aceptar el chat
estaría súper o escribir no te preocupes
ok
también nosotros los recursos que
tenemos es a qué actividad si yo hago
clic aquí en actividad aquí me voy a
decir perfectamente bien cuánto tiempo
ha participado ha entrado cada uno de
mis alumnos a khan academy durante horas
de escuela y fuera de las horas de
escuela la parte oscura de la gráfica me
indica fuera de la escuela la parte
clarita dentro de la escuela esto
obviamente yo tengo que aclarar cuáles
son las horas de la escuela no durante
los últimos siete días durante los
últimos 30 días durante los últimos dos
días ayer etcétera ahora si yo hago clic
en cada gráfica fíjense me dice alma
noriega hasta un total de 19 minutos en
la plataforma me dice los vídeos que ha
visto las habilidades que ha practicado
no en este caso por ejemplo
en el caso mío no a 14 minutos los
vídeos que ha visto las pruebas que ha
practicado profe norma los min 16
minutos el vídeo que los dos vídeos que
vio las habilidades que práctico
entonces si yo asigno 30 minutos
semanales a mis estudiantes para
practicar en khan academy aquí
automáticamente yo puedo ver el día de
ayer quienes practicaron o el día de por
ejemplo muerte de una persona o el día
de hoy etcétera no entonces quienes
practicaron en en la plataforma
realmente cumplieron con el requisito la
mejor de media hora o de una hora
etcétera no entonces este es otro tipo
de no de recursos o de de reporte que
tenemos si queremos enfocarnos más al
tiempo más que al avance no en cuanto a
unidades etcétera
no va a regresar aquí a la presentación
aquí en la presentación dispongo también
cuáles son estos estos reportes a los
que tenemos acceso recuerden avance por
alumno para irnos enfocarnos más en cada
uno de los alumnos o también por
unidades
y vamos a ver cuáles son las ideas no
cómo podemos participar en campeonato
bueno cuáles son los objetivos del
campeonato yo creo que es súper
importante más en las materias que
nosotros estamos impartiendo poder
motivar a nuestros alumnos no la mayoría
de los alumnos entra con terror en
matemáticas de ciencias y necesitamos
cambiar este enfoque no nuestros
estudiantes estamos más alumnos que que
se dediquen a ciencias que les gusten
las matemáticas no entonces creo que
campeonato lo que ofrece es la
oportunidad de trabajar en equipo de de
tener un logro como un objetivo en común
no trabajar por algo en conjunto y eso
siempre motiva a los alumnos nos a
empezar compitiendo o pesar este
como en conjunto en grupo junto con el
profesor trabajando en un logro común
siempre nos va a motivar y sobre todo va
a crear una relación muy estrecha con el
profesor es por eso que a mí me encanta
este programa porque de verdad considero
que es una manera increíble de comenzar
el año escolar no con objetivos altos
objetivos importantes pero sobre todo
reconociendo ese logro ese esfuerzo de
nuestros alumnos entonces establecer
objetivos grupales e individuales que
sean ambiciosos y realistas también nos
ha no podemos poner a objetivos que
están poco realistas o inalcanzables
porque entonces viene la frustración y
bueno por parte de canadá de mí está
implementando un sistema de recompensas
y de incentivos para motivar a nuestros
alumnos y para reconocer no solamente en
los alumnos sino también en los
profesores sus esfuerzos y logros
a una parte importante de las que le
vamos a que vamos a platicar las
habilidades son las mentalidades la
mentalidad de crecimiento y estas
actividades que vamos a ir asignando
también durante campeonatos
cada semana junto con nuestras tres
actividades actividades vamos a asignar
a nuestros alumnos una actividad de
mentalidad de crecimiento que no tienen
nada que ver con matemáticas ni
conciencias no entonces vamos a
platicarles un poquito más de esto pero
cómo pueden ustedes desafiar a sus
alumnos motivarlos etcétera pueden a lo
mejor llevar a cabo una competencia no
dentro del salón de clases o con con
otros salones de clases para ver qué
clase llega al 100% no de cada semana o
de cada nivel etcétera pueden por
ejemplo a los alumnos que completen
primero esos tres recursos darles
boletos que puedan intercambiar después
amor por un premio no un diploma un
lápiz no es algo que ustedes quieran
darles al final de cada semana reconocer
el esfuerzo de sus alumnos celebrar los
logros y esto puede ser digo yo en mi
caso a veces les hacía les llevaba una
pizza
o donas o este no sé no es un pastel o
pero lo que sea no desde un diploma
hasta un póster hasta hacer que se
levanten en clase y se les aplauda
reconocerlos en una ceremonia de toda la
escuela no no sé si tienen ceremonias de
no de la bandera en las semanalmente
hacer un espacio para reconocer a las
clases que han logrado estos objetivos
pero lo importante no es tanto el cómo
pero el que se haga no que reconozcamos
a los alumnos pueden escoger por ejemplo
pueden crear un tablero de anuncios no y
pueden poner las tareas completadas el
nivel que han logrado los alumnos las
medallas que han ganado etcétera
pero si es importante como les digo
recompensarlos con algún incentivo que
les funcione a cada uno de ustedes nadie
mejor que ustedes conoce a sus alumnos
entonces eso es importante que ustedes
diseñan un plan o un plan para
motivarlos para no para celebrarlos
etcétera no personaliza en el título del
premio como les dé se organicen una
fiesta con pizza con donas con helado
con lo que quiera no sea usted o con un
dulce lo que ustedes quieran pero lo
importante aquí es reconocerlos
motivarlos tener la razón y antes antes
de que usted les digamos a madres que
hay diferentes maneras de maneras de
manejar esto nos y dos maneras que lo
podemos ver es hay personas que les
gusta competir y hay personas que no les
gusta competir entonces si ven que hay
por ejemplo un grupo que quiere competir
con el otro grupo pues hagan una
competencia entre grupos pero si ven que
tienen alumnos que les gusta más
colaborar
entonces hagan grupos en los que haya un
líder y es el líder pues les les incite
a los demás alumnos a compartir a ayudar
a hacer las tareas para lograr lograr el
objetivo común
exacto y bueno recuerden que el
campeonato es un programa
vamos a asignar es una combinación de
ejercicios vídeos recursos y actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento no para que
realmente logremos aumentar la confianza
y la motivación de nuestros alumnos
tanto en clase de mate como en en
ciencias no el campeonato empieza hoy
finalmente llegó el gran día
recuerden que va a aparecer este banner
en el momento en que entren a campeonato
a buena khan academy con que hagan clic
en el botón de inscríbete
automáticamente quedan ya inscritos
eliminen sus clases viejas maestros
recuerden eso pónganlo así como punto
número uno y vamos a crear ya las nuevas
y este ya ya comenzar a asignar nuestros
tres recursos
que deben hacer como profesores para
tener éxito en campeonato recuerden
eliminar sus clases inactivas agregar
sus clases nuevas asegúrense de invitar
a más de diez alumnos recuerden también
asignar tres recursos por semana durante
las diez semanas que dure campeonato a
todos sus alumnos revisen el tablero del
progreso y celebren el logros los
alumnos podrían a lo mejor asignar un
día a la semana el viernes a lo mejor
que es cuando no está como que ya todos
los alumnos entregaron sus tareas pero
que pónganse un día para revisar en
grupo el tablero del progreso del que
vamos a hablar ahorita y motiven a sus
alumnos a continuar trabajando por él no
por el éxito por el logro
y celebrando sus esfuerzos los que deben
hacer los alumnos para tener éxito en
campeonato completar los ejercicios que
les va a enviar su profesor eso sí a su
propio ritmo en su propio espacio
etcétera realizar las actividades
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
realizar también periódicamente su
progreso a través del tablero y celebrar
el mismo canadá junto con sus compañeros
su profesor sus logros y el el alcance
de sus metas
el tablero del progreso que es el
tablero del progreso tabla progreso es
este tablero el que van a tener ustedes
acceso una vez que se inscriban en
campeonato y qué es lo que les va a
permitir ir midiendo cuál es su avance
dentro del campeonato no recuerden que
son 10 semanas vamos a tener siete
niveles y entonces aquí tienen por
ejemplo les voy a enseñar un ejemplo de
cómo funciona el tablero del progreso no
entonces impartir una cosa gráfica que
sepan porque si antes si había niveles
determinados en la versión de eeuu pero
la de ahora la actualizada es tantos
niveles como ellos quieran exacto y si
no me faltó agregar eso se excede y algo
que deben de saber es un momento de
celebración y ahorita les vamos a dar
una demostración de cómo funciona pero
no a todos los momentos de celebración
son iguales entonces conforme más
avancen más sorpresas van saliendo
entonces lo que les sugerimos es que
vean la demostración de cómo funciona el
tablero
porque una vez que tú le des este click
al botón de revisar mi progreso y les
explicaba hace un momento de celebración
no se puede rebobinar en ese momento
entonces asegúrense que sus alumnos
estén cerca para ver el momento el
momento en que toda la clase puede ser
exacto no esto es aquí por ejemplo me
dice completa 75 tareas obviamente las
tareas de la eba calcular dependiendo
número de alumnos que ustedes tienen en
su clase no considerando que son tres
tareas por estudiante entonces
a medida que los alumnos van contestando
no se va
y el porcentaje va a ir aumentando hasta
que finalmente llegan al 100% y ahí es
el momento de celebrar no hay es el
momento de emocionarse del tablero
también se los va a reconocer de que
están alcanzando en el nivel 0 y ha
pedido que vayamos subiendo obviamente
la idea es completar el 100% en cada
nivel y ahí vienen las sorpresas no para
para celebrar este logro no entonces
cuál es nuestra idea
ahí está dice bueno este es cuando
llegan ellos al 100% el tablero se lo
celebra etcétera y esto es en sí la idea
no todos de iu
estación y preparaos para darles un
dulce no sea un reconocimiento para que
no solo
para los reconozca sino también nosotros
como maestros les reconozcamos ese
esfuerzo y ese logro
green
y el tablero del progreso no nos va a
indicar el nivel logrado a través del
programa y los alumnos van a ir
recibiendo premios digitales que están
hechos y creados especialmente para este
programa
no sé si quieras pasar estos vídeos
porque
si quieres comparte tu pantalla y
muéstrales estos ejemplos de cómo cómo
se ven los alumnos así como venden
perfecto sí sí sí ahorita mismo
no les va a compartir estos dos vídeos
de cómo los alumnos
celebran sus logros y luego lo mucho que
se emociona no entonces esto es lo que
yo creo que como docentes nos toca hacer
que los chavos emociones se motiven en
nuestras clases adelante de honor
con falta
estos son unos alumnos que hasta
abrazaron a la maestra y los tenemos
aquí en eeuu
[Música]
a ver a ver
a
ahora
para atrás
y algo que me gustaría decirles a todos
es que esto este programa es nuevo en
méxico este
y está corriendo al mismo tiempo en la
india y en eeuu entonces es muy muy
importante que todos ustedes si
participan nos compartan lo que están
haciendo en su salón de clases
y pongan ahorita les vamos a compartir
el hashtag y todo lo que están hemos
pensado para que lo reconozcamos a
ustedes porque si ustedes no comparten
con nosotros pues estos momentos alguna
algún comentario que tenga en el
programa como les ha ayudado es difícil
para nosotros medir este qué impacto
está teniendo este exacto
exacto
y pues bueno vamos a hablar también
ahorita de mentalidad de crecimiento que
es algo creado también bueno creado para
khan academy y que vamos a empujar mucho
aquí durante campeonato y ahorita les
vamos a contar el porqué les voy a
compartir este vídeo que bueno me parece
realmente increíble no la posibilidad
que nos ofrecen este tipo de actividades
vamos a verlo
el doctor y vean
voy a hacer un paréntesis para quienes
no saben que esta persona está sal que
él es el fundador de dell
bueno esto ya van tres
el sol
el ministerio prestar y william sound
records mind sed
com
souza
engage
na
the sun
manchester war street is the rye días
servidas
x
desde la intersección de interés por la
ciudad del actual ciclo por rock and
action de brainware telegraph
bueno pues a cada cara me nos ofrece de
verdad una serie de actividades para
desarrollar esto voy a sonar esta parte
para que no se vaya a activar
y cuáles son estas actividades vamos a
a verlas acá no los alumnos con una
mentalidad de crecimiento de verdad que
tienen niveles más altos no que aquellos
que tienen una mentalidad fija sabemos y
lo sabemos como más maestros de
matemáticas y de ciencias que nuestros
alumnos generalmente entran a nuestras
clases ya con una mentalidad de fracaso
y ya con una mentalidad hecha de yo no
puedo a mí matemáticas no se me dan yo
no nací para esto etcétera no entonces
este este tipo de actividades es la idea
de este tipo de actividades es provocar
ese cambio en la mentalidad de los
jóvenes no que realmente sean más
positivos más perseverantes y más sexy
exitosos
la mentalidad del crecimiento bueno
cuáles son las ventajas de esta
mentalidad de crecimiento versus una
mentalidad fija y yo creo que la
mentalidad de crecimiento lo que más
promueve es la creencia de que yo puedo
no y a lo mejor tendré errores ya lo
mejor tendré fracasos pero esos deben no
derrumbarme sino al contrario no
motivarme a seguir intentándolo no a
seguir creciendo a seguir al no logrando
mis objetivos no entonces crece con
esfuerzo y estrategias los alumnos van
aprendiendo cómo funciona su cerebro
cuáles son esas estrategias de
aprendizaje que funcionan para ellos
cada uno de nuestros alumnos es muy
diferente y tienen diferentes
estrategias y formas de aprender lo que
me gusta a mí de estas actividades es
que precisamente los alumnos empiezan a
entender cómo aprenden cómo aprenden
ellos y cuáles son las estrategias que
funcionan para ellos no se van centrando
en el proceso de aprendizaje
no en el resultado no no en si logras un
resultado o no porque finalmente la idea
es que logren la victoria y logren su
objetivo no importa a través de cuántos
intentos no la mentalidad fija no es al
contrario es la creencia de que no puedo
no hay mi cerebro no da más
mi cerebro así nací así me crearon así
así esta fe y nacemos con esta
mentalidad de que me mi cerebro no no no
puede pensar más no puede dar más
entonces no puede entender más no
entonces tenemos esta mentalidad fija
y pensamos que nunca vamos a conseguir
algo que pueda ser algo más grande no se
va centrando en el resultado y sólo
tiene dos opciones éxito o fracaso
entonces cuál es la
el fundamento de estas actividades de
mentales de crecimiento es conocer cómo
funciona nuestro cerebro como cómo
funciona cuál es el motor cómo nos
motivamos cómo cómo podemos continuar
perseverando no que vos vamos a escuchar
la del éxito o la del fracaso cómo
podemos convertir nuestros errores en
oportunidades para tener éxito no
superando obviamente la frustración la
desmotivación etcétera y solamente
enfocándonos en el camino hacia adelante
las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento bueno fue están
desarrolladas por bird que es un centro
de estudios es de stanford a través de
las investigaciones de carol dweck como
vimos en el vídeo y nuevamente no la
idea es fijarnos o fijar nuestra mente
en un crecimiento no hay que nuestra
mente puede crecer puede puede mejorar
puede ser todavía mucho más avanzada
digamos no contra la idea de que nuestra
mentalidad y es fija sin así así me
hicieron
cambiar este chip en los jóvenes de que
bueno yo creo que en los jóvenes ya
nosotros no yo creo que también como
adultos crecimos con este concepto de
este pavor y horror y miedo al fracaso
no así crecimos dos años nos dan miedo a
veces participar en algo por el volvió
al fracaso por el miedo a la burla por
miedo
qué dirán y yo creo que hay que cambiar
ese switch y no solamente en matemáticas
en ciencias sino en nuestros jóvenes en
cualquier situación no porque al final
la vida está llena de oportunidades de
retos etcétera y cuando los jóvenes
cambian está esta idea de que los
errores son no son un fracaso son un
camino al fracaso y lo convierten no lo
ven como una oportunidad de aprendizaje
automáticamente
cambia también su perspectiva sobre
muchas cosas en la vida no nos ayuda a
superar la frustración a crear nuevas
estrategias no para tener éxito crear
metas y sobretodo mentalizarse para el
éxito no no no para el fracaso entonces
tenemos varios varios recursos varias
guías no se creó un currículum dirigido
especialmente a primaria secundaria y
bachillerato ahorita les voy a dar la
liga y yo no nos va a hacer favor de
enseñarles cómo podemos acceder a estas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
entonces
aquí sea con clic aquí ustedes aquí en
su presentación automáticamente se va a
abrir el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento automáticamente si se fijan
tenemos actividades para primaria y
secundaria y actividades de bachillerato
que lo ven acá
con eso no entonces por ejemplo aquí en
parte 1 la parte no soy la verdad acerca
de tu cerebro entonces van a ir leyendo
artículos viendo vídeos etcétera
la interesa asignar al menos una
actividad no un par de ellas pero la
idea es que durante estas diez semanas
que dure el campeonato cubrir todo todas
las lecciones de lo que es ya sea prima
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 son 20 notas más o menos asignar si
son 10 semanas 22 por semana o que lo
hagan en clase etcétera la idea es
realmente darles estas estas
herramientas a los jóvenes no tan
necesarias en nuestros jóvenes para
tener éxito en general en la vida no
entonces
ahorita no sé si quieras compartir con
los maestros como pueden
acceder a este contenido y asignarlo por
favor claro que si ya esté entre ameal
esto es la plataforma no te metes como
profesor y punto que ya creaste tus
clases entonces me si es profesor de
matemáticas o de alguna otra materia y
dices bueno yo quiero además de
matemáticas dar clase este bueno darle
algunos temas de mentalidad de
crecimiento lo que tienes que hacer es
ir a tu clase auto les enseño estoy aquí
y aquí les va a aparecer primero hacen
su clase cuando ustedes ya asignaron
contenido y tienen su clase les va a
aparecer de esta manera pero si le dan
clic en esta parte que dice contenido
y aquí les va a aparecer editar cursos
editar cursos pueden añadir nuevos
cursos eso es lo que me estaban
preguntando muchos pero es que puedo dar
este otras materias dentro de mi clase
si puedes y puedes mezclarlo con otros
años con otros temas entonces uno de los
temas que les van a aparecer es este
mentalidad de crecimiento entonces lo
que tienen que hacer es este deslizar su
mouse hacia abajo y darle clic aquí su
mentalidad de crecimiento y le ponen
guardar al guardar se va a guardar este
todo lo de mentalidad de crecimiento y
al darle clic les va a aparecer todo el
contenido aquí y ustedes van a poder dar
un vistazo previo de qué se trata la
actividad
hay un vídeo ahí por ejemplo y lo que
pueden hacer es asignar o no entonces al
asignar ustedes deciden si es para se lo
asignada a todos sus estudiantes o solo
hay uno que tenga algún problema
entonces así es como lo pueden ver
también quiere crear una nueva clase
solo de mentalidad de crecimiento harían
lo mismo sería mentalidad de crecimiento
y podrían poner primero de bachillerato
y dan en bachillerato y este
y se van hasta abajo donde les mostré
les va a aparecer primero así deslizan
sumado hasta abajo le dan click aquí
se crea su clase y les va a crear un
código único cada vez que creen una
clase tienen un código único y diferente
eso es lo que les va a permitir crear
diferentes clases con diferentes
contenidos entonces si tienen un grupo
que al que le dan matemáticas ya otro
que le dan biología o eres profesor de
física entonces las matemáticas y física
pues tu código va a ser diferente para
tus clases y los van a invitar de la
manera que más les convenga ya sea por
el código por invitación de correo
electrónico invitando aquí a sus alumnos
y este una vez que agregan a sus alumnos
le dan click al botón de invitar
estudiantes
hay algunas dudas o algo que quisiera
comentar
vamos a ver
si no hay ya para acá vamos a hablar de
cuál es el el kit que acceso ahorita les
damos un espacio para que nosotros no se
nos ha olvidado y que para todos ustedes
que nos están escuchando pues tenemos
una sorpresa para ustedes porque si bien
hay premios digitales también pensamos
en todos es que están motivados por
hacer algo nuevo y más vamos a hacer
unos kits especiales para la clase les
llevamos a los procesos que estén
inscritos lo que vamos a hacer es que
vamos a hacer una selección este y les
vamos a mandar un formulario y los
primeros en inscribirse éste van a
recibir una fábrica vamos a hablar si
les va a platicar un poquito más de este
kit para billos o que planeo a adriana
para enviarles entonces bueno nada más
para acabar
qué deben hacer ustedes para promoverla
en su experiencia por favor esto es
súper importante compartan su
experiencia con nosotros sus sugerencias
sus logros
todo ahora todas las experiencias que
tengan con nosotros no para para poder
también nosotros compartirlas porque yo
creo que todos aprendemos de todos no
compartan sus historias de crecimiento
usando el hashtag campeonato 2018 en
cualquiera
están con nosotros no inscriban a sus
alumnos ganen un kit de clase el kit de
clase como comentaba adriana contiene
stickers del programa postres de
mentalidad de crecimiento lápices de
campeonato entonces estos pueden ser
cosas que motiven a sus alumnos que los
puedan motivar y empujar hacia el éxito
entonces es importante que se registren
que para que puedan tener sus correos
etcétera y puedan hacerles llegar su kit
para este este programa y como les
decimos tanto adriana como yo los
queremos de verdad motivar no a que
compartan con nosotros fotos videos así
como como vieron los vídeos que les
mucho adriana no de la emoción de los
chicos a lograr sus objetivos tómenlo
vídeo a sus alumnos compartan con
nosotros su valor a redes sociales si no
tienen una cuenta en twitter abra la
abran una cuenta como profesores es
súper importante comunicarnos compartir
nuestras experiencias porque todos
aprendemos de todos
abran su cuenta en twitter y comienzan a
tuitear no esté con el hashtag
campeonato pueden también por no poner a
khan academy con la arroba khan academy
lo van a encontrar en todas las redes y
compartir con nosotros todas todas sus
experiencias no entonces los invitamos a
seguirnos también en estas redes tanto
en facebook pueden encontrar khan
academy en español
entonces entren a facebook entren a
busquen khan academy en español
además les va a encantar porque tiene
una serie de vídeos de no de información
extra y sobre todo ahorita información
de campeonato entren a este vida a
facebook síganos en la canaca de mi
español en twitter también nos pueden
seguir en khan academy al igual que en
instagram
y pues por mi parte es todo no sé si
haya algo más
a granito
no es muy importante esas fotos que les
compartimos del kitsch solo es una
muestra obviamente más estampa y
estampas y con diseños diferentes
es importante que nos compartan pues
estos momentos de alegría con su clase
porque como les decía pues es la única
manera que nos podemos enterar es ya sea
que nos escriban al correo de campeonato
khan academy punto hereje o pongan el
twitter en twitter o en facebook lo que
ustedes usen el hashtag que diga hashtag
campeonato porque es la manera de que
nosotros podemos pues compartir eso en
nuestras redes sociales entonces les
agradeceríamos muchísimo que pues si
tienen ya los que empezaron a hacer sus
sus tareas y revisaron juntos el tablero
es muy importante esto por favor para
los nuevos que se acaban de unir no le
den click a revisar el progreso del
tablero si no están sus alumnos
alrededor porque no se puede rebobinar
el momento de celebración entonces
tienen que tener mucho cuidado con sus
alumnos estén ahí con ustedes
exacto y bueno obtienes la presentación
cualquier cosa recurren a la
presentación y si no pueden contactarnos
ya sea a través de las redes sociales
eleonor tenemos un correo también de lo
puedes compartir por favor
claro que sí ahorita para que vean el
correo del campeonato es campeonato
arroba khan academy punto o hereje
los que los escribo en el chat en el
chat ya pueden muchas gracias que tengan
todos una muy buena tarde mucho éxito en
este reto en este está en este programa
la verdad que esperamos a no recibir
mucha retroalimentación y muchos casos
de éxito y bueno les deseo lo mejor para
este inicio de clases un abrazo a todos
y gracias por su esfuerzo por su energía
por todo el trabajo que hacen como
maestros como dice salvamos méxico vamos
méxico un abrazo a los récords de la
india y de eeuu
yo sé que mis profesores mexicanos son
los más motivados me encanta trabajar
con ustedes les mando un abrazo bayle
bike mucho éxito chau